Thank you.
It's great to be
back with everybody.
It's been quite a while since
I've seen so many faces.
And this is awesome.
I love being here and I
love being here with you.
Like Tatu said,
the name of my talk
is R, Python, and Tableau
A Love Triangle
Some of you may recognize this
goes back to a few years ago.
We ran it, we did a talk and
we did an advertising campaign
around R and Python,
a love story.
And as I was getting
ready for this talk,
this title just seemed
to write itself.
And I was like, this is
just too good to pass up on.
And then I started preparing
the talk and I was like,
love triangles
are kind of awful.
They don't end well.
Like nothing works
out. Like this--
Trying to make an
analogy between a love
triangle and these
three different tools
that I hope to illustrate
work really well together
wasn't working out for me.
And so we're going
to pivot a little bit
and we'll actually be
talking a little bit,
we'll be drawing some
comparisons to music today,
and I hope that's OK.
So to start, we're going listen
to a couple of audio samples
from perhaps one of
the most famous pieces
of classical music.
You'll likely recognize
it even if you
don't know the name or the
composer or anything like that.
We'll see if this works.
So we'll listen to
this first one here.
So some of you may recognize
that that's the beginning
of Beethoven's Fifth symphony.
Some of the most famous
pieces, famous measures
of classical music ever heard.
Now we're going to
listen to one more
version of those same
few measures of music
and then compare the two.
OK. Same music, same notes.
Slightly different.
In the first case, we just
have the piano and nothing
against the piano.
I'm a pianist.
I have
I've been a pianist since
I was five years old.
I love the piano,
but it can't quite
compare to the richness
of a full symphony.
As we add additional
musical instruments,
as we layer in
additional components,
the depth of the music grows.
And we can hear that
in the two examples
we just looked at.
Today, we're going
to look at how we can do
the same with our analyses.
If we start with a
basic Tableau dashboard,
how can we add additional
tools and bring
additional technologies
to that dashboard
to add additional
depth of insight
to what we're delivering
to our business users?
Here's kind of an
example dashboard.
This is a pretty straightforward
data exploration dashboard
that allows a user to
explore a given data set.
I can choose an x axis,
I can choose a y axis,
I can explore the relationship
between two features.
In this case, this data
set is a collection
of attributes from
different pieces of music,
different genres of
music, different songs
from those genres.
How popular were they?
How danceable are they?
How likable are they?
What the tempo is,
things of that nature.
So I can create comparisons
between classical music and hip hop
or instrumental music or
electronic music if I want to.
And a user can come in
here and explore and start
to determine their own insights
and arrive at conclusions based
on what they're looking
at in this data.
Now, if we wanted to take
this to another level
and add additional
details to it,
we might want to look to
add some machine learning
capabilities here.
What if we tried to predict
the popularity of a song
based on different attributes?
And how could we evaluate
the effectiveness
of different models
we might be using?
To kind of illustrate
this example,
I'm actually going
to turn to my son.
I have a two-year-old son he
just turned two a couple of days
ago.
His name is Forrest.
Here he is.
This picture was taken
just before I left.
And as you can tell from this
photo, he's a bit random.
So we are going to be training
a random forest model today.
In R, what this might look
like is something like this.
We'll bring in a package
like the ranger package
and we can write a simple
function that takes some input
data (x and y), trains a model,
spits out the predicted values
based on the training
data that we supplied.
Now, for all the
machine learning experts
in the audience, this is not
a course on machine learning.
So please recognize that
this is perhaps a bit overly
simplistic, but it should help
us highlight and understand
how these different components
can all fit together.
If I wrote a function
like this in R and that
I wanted that function to be
accessible to other tools.
Right we're going to ignore
Tableau for a moment and just
say, look, I want some generic
other service to have access
to this thing that I wrote.
The best and easiest
way to do that in R
is using the plumber package,
and here's an example
of what that might look like.
If I bring in the
plumber package,
first of all, I have to bring
the package into my workspace,
and then all I need to do is
add a few special comments
to my script that
indicate, hey, this
should be an API that's
listening for requests
from other services.
It's very straightforward
and easy to use,
especially if I'm already
used to using R.
Now let's take that and make
it a little bit more specific.
Let's say that instead of just
any generic service out there,
I actually want this to be
used from within Tableau.
I want Tableau to be able to
submit data to this function.
And I want this function
to execute and return
the data back to Tableau.
Well, I could write my own
very unique API to do that,
or I could use the
plumbertableau package, which
handles a lot of the
specifics behind the scenes
to make this API work,
specifically with Tableau
workbooks and dashboards.
As you notice, again, I've
highlighted the differences
here between a
traditional plumber
API and this new plumbertableau
API, and they're very minimal.
I bring in the
plumbertableau package.
I had a few additional comments
that indicate what type of data
I'm expecting from
tableau, what type of data
I'm going to be
returning to Tableau.
And then the most
significant piece
is that piece
there at the bottom
where I indicate that I'm
creating a Tableau extension.
If we do the same thing
on the Python side,
we could bring in scikit-learn.
We could define a function
that creates and trains
a random forest
and again spits out
the predicted outcomes
based on the input data
that we received.
If I want to make this a
generically available service,
I could use a tool
like FastAPI.
I can bring in the
FastAPI module.
I can define an app and
then I can define routes
on that app that are
functions that are
listening for incoming input.
Just like we saw on the R
side with plumbertableau,
there's a new package
called FastAPITableau
that does the same thing.
In fact, it's maybe
even a little bit easier
than what we saw on the
plumbertableau side,
because all I need
to do is change
import FastAPI to
import FastAPITableau
and I need to change
my app instantiation instead
of saying it's a Fast API app,
I now just say it's a Fast API
Tableau app.
Everything else
remains the same.
Now, once I've developed
these extensions,
I might have used RStudio
Workbench to develop these.
I might have developed
these locally,
but once I've developed
them, I need somewhere
where they can be hosted
so that I can access them
from within Tableau.
The easiest place to do
that is RStudio Connect.
And here's an example
of what it looks
like when I've published these
two extensions onto RStudio
Connect.
The first thing I'm
going to look at
is I'm going to look
at the Python extension
that we built. And
once I come in here,
you'll see that I have a nice
user interface that illustrates
to Tableau users exactly what
they need to do if they want
to use this extension.
There's also a nice feature
for the developer, which
will allow me to come in
here and test the API out,
make sure the extension is
doing what I want it to do.
Does it take data appropriately?
Does it return the
appropriate response?
Does it behave the way that
I think it should behave?
This is really nice because
as an R or a Python developer,
this means I never
have to open Tableau.
I can start from
the beginning and I
can go all the way through to a
working, functioning extension
of Tableau.
But I never have
to actually open
Tableau to verify its behavior.
If we look at the
R extension, here's
the R extension we published.
We see a similar thing.
We have a nice
interface that lets
us know how to use this
from within tableau,
and we'll take a look
at that implementation
in just a moment.
And I also have the ability,
like we saw on the Python side,
to test and verify the
behavior of this particular
of this particular extension.
I can copy output data
from somewhere else.
I can drop it in
here and I can verify
that this is, in fact
returning the results that I
would expect it to
be returning, given
the function that I defined.
Now, if we look at how to
do this within tableau,
we've tried to make
this as easy as possible
for somebody who maybe isn't
an R or Python developer,
but is a Tableau user to
be able to come in and use
an extension that
has been shared
on a platform like
RStudio Connect.
In that case, the
user might come
in to this particular page.
They'll highlight and
copy the usage section
of the documentation.
They'll move over into tableau,
create a new calculated field,
give that calculated
field some sort of a name.
In this case, we'll call this
random forest or something
to that effect, and then paste
in the data that they copied
or the script that
they copied from
the previous documentation.
Once this is copied in, the
only thing that we need to do
is we need to supply the
actual names of fields
that we want Tableau to
supply to this extension.
In this case, I
was very creative.
And so we have
X axis and Y axis,
but that allows us
to simply identify
what the x and y variables
are that we're passing
in to our underlying model.
Once this is done, I can
use the calculated field.
I can drag it into my workbook
and use it just as I would
any other variable or
feature within my data set.
So if we bring all of
these different components
together now, right, we have
this original Tableau dashboard
that allows users to
explore data, defined
x and y-axes, filtered to
specific genres of music,
identify relationships between
these different features
that they might be
interested in looking in.
And then we have these
two new extensions
that we've developed.
Both are training
random forest models,
but one is done in Python,
and one is done in R,
and they're hosted
on RStudio Connect.
If we take a look at-- if we take a look
at all these pieces
put together,
we might have something
that looks like this.
Our original dashboard
is up at the top
where users can still
define x and y axes,
investigate relationships
between different components
within the data,
but then down below, we've
added these two new plots
that indicate the residual
plots from our underlying random
forest models that we trained.
On the left, we see our
random forest model in R.
On the right, we see our
random forest model in Python.
And you'll see as I interact
with this particular dashboard,
these everything is
dynamic, everything updates
as I make changes and
adjustments to the dashboard.
So if I choose to bring
electronic music into the mix,
I'll see that first reflected
in the plot up above
and then I'll see it also
reflected in the plots
below as new data--
Once again, this is a
real time interaction.
So new data is being
submitted from Tableau
to these extensions,
some sort of
execution is happening,
and then the results are
being transmitted right back
into Tableau for
further analysis.
Now, this use case is
a little bit specific,
and the use case that we've
kind of focused on primarily
here is I'm in tableau, but I
need to do something to my data
that Tableau can't do.
And in many cases that might be
like something machine learning
or machine learning
adjacent, right?
I need to do some sort
of statistical procedure
or analysis that Tableau just
isn't fully equipped to do.
And I've had good conversations
with people at Tableau that
have indicated to
me, "Look, we're
"not we're not trying to make
Tableau a fully featured
statistical analysis engine."
And so these
extensions are the way
in which we can broaden the
horizons of what Tableau
is capable of by allowing it
to plug into other tools that
might be more effective
at certain tasks.
And we certainly might all
agree that R and Python are
two tools very well suited to
common statistical and machine
learning tasks.
There's another class
of problems, though,
and that class of problems is
I have some data in Tableau
and I have in my mind some sort
of visualization that I want
to do, but I can't do it
or it's really difficult.
And if you've ever
worked with Tableau,
I find myself in this position
pretty frequently where
I can imagine some
sort of visualization,
and then I find myself wishing
there was some sort of  ggplot
Tableau integration thing.
Well, we don't quite have that.
What we do have is a package
called shinytableau.
Shiny Tableau
And I'm not going to go through
all of the details here.
I'm going to provide links to
the documentation and things
that you can kind of
explore on your own.
But shinytableau allows
you to define a custom Shiny
application that creates a
unique extension for a Tableau
workbook.
What this looks like
is and on the left,
I have this there's a
specific manifest file
that you write when you
create these extensions.
There's some nuance to how
this gets put together.
And if you're
familiar with shiny,
it will feel comfortable
and familiar to you.
But if you're not quite
familiar with shiny, it's
a good idea to start
with Shiny first and then
look at shinytableau
as, as a second option.
But there's this
manifest file that I
create that defines the
extension and some attributes
of it.
And when I run that
Shiny application
or when I publish that Shiny
application in somewhere
like RStudio Connect,
what I end up with
is this page on the right.
This doesn't look like any
sort of Shiny application
you've likely seen before
because there's nothing
really interactive here.
Instead, what I have is a prompt
to download some sort of file.
So what I do is I download
that file locally,
and then if I'm using
Tableau desktop,
I can import that file
directly into Tableau Desktop.
If I'm using something
like Tableau Online,
I would need to put
that file in a location
where I can read it from my
Tableau Online or Tableau
Server environment.
So if we bring all this
together and take it once more
from the top, here's what
that might look like.
Here's the existing dashboard
that I have with my R and
Python extensions operating
here on the bottom.
And if I want to bring this
shinytableau extension in,
what I need to do is drag an
extension onto my dashboard,
navigate to that file
that I downloaded locally.
So here we'll see
that I can select
the file that was downloaded
from that Shiny application.
Once that's
downloaded, I then need
to configure the
extension itself.
And these are all
components that you
can adjust and set up when
you define the shinytableau
extension.
I'll come in here,
I'll select the data
that I want this extension
to be reading from,
and then I'll select the values
that I want Tableau to pass
to this specific extension.
In this case, what we're going
to do once we finish this is
we'll have a nice density plot
over here on the right hand
side that demonstrates
the density of everything
along the y-axis.
And I could do the same thing
to create a density plot
along the x-axis as well,
which might be something
that I want to give me a better
understanding of the shape
of my data, especially when
I have so many data points
that I'm considering,
like I have in
this particular visualization.
One other thing that's worth
mentioning that I haven't
brought up to this
point is the fact
that, again, we have both
R and Python extensions
operating as part of the
same Tableau workbook.
RStudio Connect
is the only endpoint
that supports this idea of
both R and Python extensions
simultaneously in
the same workbook.
If you were to use something
more traditional like TabPy or
Rserve, you would be restricted
only to Python execution
or only to R execution.
But given the work that
we've done with the folks
at Tableau and the work
that we've done internally
with RStudio
Connect, RStudio
Connect can host R extensions
and Python extensions
side by side.
And they can be leveraged
from the same Tableau
environment alongside things
like shinytableau extensions
as well.
So what does this
all mean? Going back
to our music analogy,
the idea here is we can use
the right combination of tools
for the job,
And we can deliver a symphony of
insight. More than just a piano
solo,
we can deliver something
that astounds and astonishes
our end users.
Now, is this necessary
every time? It's not.
I have a six-year-old daughter
who just had her first piano
recital, and it was exactly
what it needed to be.
She didn't need to be playing
the violin and the trumpet
and everything all at once.
The piano recital was enough.
And it's up to us as the data
scientists, as the analysts,
to decide what
level of insight is
the appropriate level for the
analysis that we're doing.
It's important to
understand that we
have a whole host of tools
like JJ kind of alluded
to in his talk this morning.
We continue to look
at this ecosystem
and look for ways in
which we can participate
in the broad scientific
computing ecosystem,
and that includes tools like
Tableau and the integrations
that we've done there.
If you're interested
in learning more,
there are some resources here.
There's a GitHub repository that
has several different examples
of how these different
extensions can
work with different Tableau
workbooks and things like that.
And you can learn
from those examples.
The slides and all the
content from this talk
will be made available
on GitHub shortly after
I've kind of finished
everything up today.
And finally, I just
want to say Thank you.
It's been great
being back in person.
And if there's any questions,
we can take those now.